meine damen und herren jetzt kommen
luckey bin ich nicht der doch was geht
dir wie geht's hier muss zunächst oder
warum also die hände vom gesicht selbst
du gerade
die gc denn genau
hallo ich da kann man schon mal
klatschen eigentlich hast du kannst du
dir posen machen soll so was er ja klar
keine pose machen wie geht es dir denn
was machst du gerade
ich komme aus garmisch ja bei der
zugspitze lernst du kannst du vor uns
auf der zugspitze fenster schaut sich
die zugspitze das ist die spitze vom zug
riesen fan die ich einfach mehr
spendieren ganz ehrlich ich hab gerade
auch mit am ersten sechs und kommt ja
neues merchandise der webcam hast du
nicht oder
hallo ich bin gar joggen
ja und da hab ich mir gedacht nebenbei
ein bisschen omega ja ich laufe aber
auch nicht so schnell gerade halt s maul
ich machen großen ja klar ich grüße
laser luca als klar schöne grüße an die
beiden okay hast du ein hund warum nicht
warum soll ich nun kam weil hunde cool
sind ich will auch einen hund als ich
will nen hund aber man also ich wirklich
keine mit obwohl warum habe ich
eigentlich kein hund ich wurde auch
allein aber ein hund ist glaube ich viel
arbeit oder also du kannst ja nicht brot
und wasser kein hund aber ich glaube man
muss man immer mit dem rausgehen und den
füttern wird fällig werden hunde einfach
so sein eigenes leben hätte wenn er so
an eine irgendwie gassi gehen würde und
sich alleine essen im supermarkt kaufen
würde
kennst du ich nicht okay
du hast der hand im gesicht
das ist auch immer eine hand jetzt hast
du zwei händen im gesicht
es ist halb vier und liegt noch immer im
bett ach ja wenn man krank ist dann darf
man da hast du die grippe ich hatte aber
nur noch es nur noch so viel also nur
noch soviel okay ja das ist ja gar nicht
mehr soviel ja gar kein problem ist es
40 euro bitte überweisen morgen morgen
mir ich brauche die heute kann ich kein
patch produkt ehrlich wie heißt sie
kommentare crew member sack lassen likes
gesehen obwohl dank verkraften
die ich begeistert sie gab bei meinem
instagram so ein bild von seinem golden
retriever denn so ein handtuch
eingewickelt ist hier auch in räumen
hallo auf der plattform vor allem weil
die alle nur so mit ihrem alter kein
bild welt und ja ich bin immer bevor ich
so ein video aufnehmen bin ich auch
immer so ohne webcam unterwegs zum
zugucken wie oft schon einige leute da
sind und da sehe ich auch immer das ok
jeder wenn du kein bild dass jeder es
gibt so direkt weiter dass obama so die
ganze zeit dann muss man gucken einfach
so 2000 leute oder ok ja krass wissen
wozu wir sind heute abend im bootshaus
tatsächlich blacklisten ich black lässt
war vor zwei wochen aber heute ist so
glaube ich und brooks legen auf ich habe
mal wenn ich glaub ich getroffen wir
haben uns in vanity getroffen
na hey den mikros mega gut das glaube
ich auch
du redest sehr gut erst mal nach
ja ja ja
wie finden zufrieden frieden besser oder
krieg jetzt richtig scheiße ja ich war
richtig war im krieg ja das war eine tat
belasten das war im irak 1980 auch im
krieg und zwar so 1970 oder so keine
ahnung okay ja da war ich da war ich
nicht da konnte ich nicht aber ich war
da schon
ich hatte da zu tun deswegen die wollen
dass ich habe aber ab ging nicht ja war
ganz lager ganz toller zufall da hat
meine oma geburtstagen meinte die hey
wir haben gerade krieg aber alkomaten
kuchen gefragt so allerdings will ich an
der stelle das heutige video jetzt auch
beenden meine damen und herren wenn euch
die serie oracle mit luca gefällt und
eventuell nächstes wochenende nächsten
paar haben wollt dann lasst mal 70.000
likes da freunde das ist eine
unglaublich riesige zahl aber ich weiß
es jeder schaffen könnt und alle fragen
mal nach diesem format also go ahead
und jetzt würde ich an der stelle
eigentlich nur noch sagen